[Musique]
depuis le jeudi 1er septembre les salles
de classe des 57 collèges publics du
haut rhin sont à nouveau remplis coup
d'envoi d'une nouvelle année scolaire
pour trente six mille cinq cents élèves
ce que les jeunes 6e le savent peut-être
pas encore mais qu'ils auront le temps
d'apprendre ici le passage du brevet
c'est que le conseil départemental va
veiller sur eux pendant leurs quatre
prochaines années de scolarité
partenaire principal de l'éducation
nationale dans les collèges
l'institution rempli de nombreuses
missions indispensables au bon
apprentissage des élèves budget total 74
millions d'euros soit 2000 euros par
collégien des transports aux projets
pédagogiques en passant par les
bâtiments le département intervient dans
quasiment tous les aspects de la
scolarité de ces jeunes démonstration
avec la journée type d'un collégien
19h55 collège de lutterbach
les bustes ramène un flot d'élèves
encore un peu endormis ils sont ainsi
28000 à être chaque jour transportés par
ce service fournie par le département en
dehors de mulhouse colmar et saint louis
une prestation qui cette année comme les
précédentes restent gratuites pour les
familles c'était une volonté politique
du département du haut-rhin
effectivement vous savez que la
compétence transport des collégiens
passent à la région grand est en 2017
alors pour cette dernière année le
département souhaitait vraiment
maintenir la gratuité la gratuité
apporte beaucoup aux familles parce que
les coûts de rentrée sont énormes
néanmoins conjoncturellement aujourd'hui
les transports c'est quelque chose d
extrêmement coûteux pour les
collectivités et on ne sait pas si ce
maintien de la gratuité pourra durer
longtemps
[Musique]
8h la sonnerie retentit
les élèves se pressent devant les salles
de cours et s'ils peuvent s'y rendre
sans craindre de prendre un bout de
plafond sur la tête c'est que le conseil
départemental veille au bon entretien
des lieux au quotidien grâce au travail
de ses agents techniques des collèges
mais aussi par une vaste politique
d'investissement dans les bâtiments ici
à lutterbach ces 2,2 millions d'euros
qui ont été investis en 2016 il y a eu
des investissements 2004 2005 et dans
les années suivant pour
réorganiser tous les bâtiments que
mettre à niveau et puis il y a une
dernière phase qui date qui va se
terminer cette année sur la mise aux
normes de deux bâtiments pour y
accueillir des sections ne s'est pas
investir dans les collèges ne permet pas
seulement d'améliorer la qualité du bâti
cela a un impact direct sur la pédagogie
il faut donner aussi à nos jeunes des
des environnements de travail
épanouissant
qui permettent à la fois la personnalité
et au développement intellectuel un
petit peu de pouvoir se faire dans de
bonnes conditions et donc il faut aussi
aujourd'hui trouver des locaux qui
s'adapte aux nouvelles pédagogies
suite du programme un petit cours de
sport nous sommes dans le cosec de
lutterbach juste à côté du collège et
6,6 entraîne peut-être de futurs
champions de volley ball cela n'aurait
pas été possible sans le soutien du
département qui a soutenu la commune
pour la construction de cette salle il y
à une salle des sports à lutterbach qui
est une salle qui a permis qui est
mutualisé si vous voulez avec les
activités sportives associatives de la
commune et avec le collège le sport
c'est surtout l'ouverture
le lien avec les autres le travail
d'équipé c'est une vraie culture c'est
également quelque chose qui permet aux
jeunes de s'épanouir et évidemment de
préserver aussi leur santé et de
s'occuper de leur corps
et on va leur faire une
le volley ball c'est sûr ça vous creusez
un jeune c'est pour cela que ça s'active
dans les cuisines du collège au menu
boeuf bourguignon et poissons à la crème
330 repas à servir chaque midi les
agents du conseil départemental ne chôme
pas engagés dans l'opération plaisir à
la cantine le collège et le département
associé leurs efforts pour que le repas
soit un véritable tant d'autres aux sont
engagé une réflexion sur le vivre
ensemble et l'éducation au goût au
travers de la valorisation de produits
issus des filières bio des courtes
aujourd'hui il faut absolument
privilégier la qualité de ce que met
dans l'assiette de nos jeunes puisque
les cantines c'est aussi l'éducation à
l'alimentation c'est un enseignement
essentiel un vraiment parce que ce sont
nos citoyens de demain je crois qu'il ne
faut jamais perdre de vue que nos
enfants ce sont nos citoyens de demain
et ces enfants là eh bien il faut les
ouvrir non seulement à des connaissances
à de la culture mais également à la vie
locale et à la vie de citoyen
responsable
après le repas place aux langues nous
sommes au collège hector berlioz à
colmar un des 37 établissements du
département à proposer un cursus
bilingue ici les élèves ont un
enseignement renforcé en allemand qui
leur permet de suivre les cours
différentes matières dans la langue de
goethe s'ouvrir aux langues c'est
s'ouvrir au monde mais dans notre région
frontalière l'apprentissage de la langue
du voisin revêt une importance
particulière
il ya aussi l'aspect économique on sait
quand même que l'allemagne et la suisse
sont des pays qui ont un développement
économique important et du coup
effectivement il ya de l'emploi et bien
formons nos jeunes à pouvoir accéder à
cet emploi c'est aussi quelque chose
d'essentiel donc le bilinguisme c'est au
niveau des écoles et c'est aussi au
niveau des collèges puisqu'il y a quand
même un collège sur cinq qui permet aux
enfants qui ont fait du bilinguisme à
l'école élémentaire de continuer leur
filière
la sonnerie retentit c'est la fin des
cours le collégien s'apprête à rentrer
chez eux place aux le voir et voilà
peut-être le seul moment de leur journée
ou le conseil départemental ne sera pas
leur côté le polycopié c'est pour
mercredi